>> Tucker: WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING.
THIS IS THE SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY LABOR DAY.
IT’S THE LAST WEEKEND OF SUMMER.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS NOT A
NORMAL LABOR DAY.
IT HASN’T BEEN A NORMAL SUMMER.
AND MANY PLACES, POLITICIANS
STILL MONITOR AND CONTROL THE
MOST INTIMATE DETAILS OF YOUR
LIFE.
WHERE YOU EAT, WHO YOU SPEND
TIME WITH AND WHERE, HOW MANY
RELATIVES WHO INVITE TO YOUR
WEDDING, WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN
HOLD YOUR PARENT’S HAND ON THEIR
DEATHBED.
THE PRETEXT FOR THESE CONTROLS
IS THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD GO OUT
ON THIS LONG.
WE WERE TOLD WE HAD 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD.
WE THOUGHT THAT MEANT 15 DAYS.
VERY LITERAL.
BUT 15 DAYS BECAME 170 DAYS.
AND STILL GOING.
PEOPLE LIKE TONY FAUCI SHOWED
UP.
HE SEEMED REASONABLE AT FIRST.
IN JANUARY, HE SAID THAT
LOCKDOWNS OF THE KIND THAT CHINA
IMPOSE WOULD NEVER HAPPEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
HE ALSO SAID YOU DON’T NEED TO
WEAR A MASK.
HE ALSO INSISTED THE VIRUS WAS A
MAJOR THREAT HERE.
HE SET ALL OF THAT.
WATCH.
>> BOTTOM LINE, WE HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THIS ONE, RIGHT?
>> WHILE, OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND DO THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT THE CDC
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ARE DOING.
BUT THIS IS NOT A MAJOR THREAT
TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THE CITIZENS OF
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT.
>> Tucker: DON’T WORRY ABOUT
IT.
TOTALLY FINE.
THAT’S WHAT TONY FAUCI TOLD US
IN JANUARY PEERED BY THE WAY, WE
DIDN’T TAKE THAT OUT OF
CONTEXT.
THAT IS NOT AN ISOLATED QUOTE.
HIS LATEST IS MARCH.
THIS MARCH, STANDING AT A
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
BRIEFING, TONY FAUCI DID NOT
OPPOSE THE IDEA OF GATHERING
INDOORS FOR AN INDOOR CAMPAIGN
RALLY.
BUT THEN MORE PEOPLE STARTED
DYING.
FEDERAL OFFICIALS PANICKED AND
THE ELEVATED TONY TO A POLICY
ADVISOR.
AND THAT WAS A PIVOT POINT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE OATH IS DO NO HARM AND IT
WORKS IN THE CASE OF
DR. -PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
BUT IT DOES NOT WORK WHEN YOU’RE
TRYING TO RUN A GOVERNMENT.
PARTICULARLY WITHIN A COUNTRY AS
BIG AS THIS ONE.
EVERYTHING HAS A TRADE-OFF.
EVERYTHING IN LIFE HAS A
TRADE-OFF BETWEEN EFFICIENCY AND
THE VALUE OF HUMAN LIFE.
IF WE CAUGHT ALL SPEED LIMIT TO
10 MILES PER HOUR, THOUSANDS OF
LIVES WOULD BE SAVED BUT WE
DON’T DO THAT, SAD AS IT IS.
WE KEEP THE SPEED LIMIT HIGHER
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
RISK, EVEN REAL RISK,
POTENTIALLY FATAL RISKS ARE
NECESSARY IF YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE A FUNCTIONING SOCIETY.
THAT IS JUST THE TRUTH.
BUT TONY FAUCI CAN IT SEE THAT.
HE SUGGESTED OTHERWISE PEERED SO
BY APRIL, HE WAS WORRIED THAT
EVEN SHAKING HANDS COULD BE TOO
DANGEROUS.
>> I DON’T THINK WE EVER SHOULD
SHAKE HANDS EVER AGAIN TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
NOT ONLY WOULD IT BE GOOD TO
PREVENT THE CORONAVIRUS.
IT WOULD PROBABLY DECREASE
INFLUENZA DRAMATICALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: OKAY, SO THAT IS
EXTREMISM.
IT IS NOT BALANCING THE COST AND
BENEFIT OF A RECOMMENDATION OR
MANDATE.
HE WAS FIGURING THIS OUT AS HE
WENT ALONG, JUST LIKE THE REST
OF US ARE.
THAT IS NOT A SIN, BY THE WAY.
EVERYBODY DOES IT.
THIS IS NOT NEW.
YOU WEREN’T ALLOWED TO POINT OUT
SOME OF HIS RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
JUST SILLY.
NOT ALL, BUT SOME.
THE SO-CALLED PROGRESSIVES HAD
FINALLY FOUND THEIR LEADING MAN
AND THEY WANTED TO PROTECT HIM
AT ALL COSTS.
JIMTHEY WERE TRYING TO DESTROY H
ASKING ABOUT QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
MANDATES THAT POLICYMAKERS WERE
DESTROYING HIM.
IT IS ABSURD.
BUT DOZENS OF MEDIA OUTLETS
REPEATED THAT TALKING POINT.
BY THE TIME TONY FAUCI DESCRIBED
HIS LOCKDOWN, HE SAID IT WAS
"INCONVENIENT," NOBODY SEEMED TO
NOTICE.
IN FACT, POLITICIANS BEGAN
ENGAGING IN AN ARMS RACE TO
IMPLEMENT THEIR OWN INCONVENIENT
REGULATIONS.
CHICAGO MAYOR SAID THAT PEOPLE
WHO WENT TO PARTIES WOULD SUFFER
STRONGER CONSEQUENCES THAN
PEOPLE WHO LOOTED TARGET.
WATCH.
>> AND THIS IS HOW IT’S GOING TO
BE.
WE WILL SHUT YOU DOWN.
WE WILL CITE YOU AND IF WE NEED
TO, WE WILL ARREST YOU AND WE
WILL TAKE YOU TO JAIL.
>> Tucker: IF ONLY SHE WAS
THAT ANGRY AT PEOPLE SHOOTING
EACH OTHER ON THE SOUTH SIDE
THAN PEOPLE MUGGING PEDESTRIANS.
BUT, SHE IS NOT.
IN LOS ANGELES, HE WENT EVEN
FURTHER THAN THAT.
HE TOOK HIS CUES FROM THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HOSTING A
GATHERING IN LOS ANGELES WILL
COST YOU YOUR WATER AND YOUR
POWER SERVICE, HE DECREED.
>> THESE LARGE PARTIES ARE
UNSAFE AND CAN COST LESS
ANGELENOS THEIR LIFE.
>> Tucker: NO SCIENCE BEHIND
THAT.
OF COURSE IT IS.
ONCE YOU GIVE POLITICIANS POWER,
THEY DON’T RELINQUISH IT.
WHY WOULD THEY?
THE STANDARDS WERE VERY LOW.
THIS WAS PROFOUNDLY EMPOWERING.
THEY LOVED IT.
THE PROBLEM WAS IT CRUSHED THE
COUNTRY.
IT CRUSHED PEOPLE.
DIVORCE RATES, FOR EXAMPLE,
SOARED BY 38%.
AT ONE POINT, NEWLYWED
SEPARATIONS DOUBLED.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND FATAL
OVERDOSES INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY.
IT WILL BE A LONG TIME.
IT IS CLEAR THAT MANY PEOPLE
DIED AS A RESULT OF IT AND MANY
MORE THOUGHT ABOUT KILLING
THEMSELVES.
ACCORDING TO CDC NUMBERS, A
QUARTER OF ALL YOUNG ADULTS
CONTEMPLATED SUICIDE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC.
REPORTEDLY, THE ONLY GROUP THAT
FOUND THE CORONAVIRUS TO BE
EMPOWERING WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE
TRYING TO WIN A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AND TRYING TO REGAIN
CONTROL OF THE SENATE AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY HAVEN’T TRIED TO HIDE THE
POLITICAL BENEFITS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
LOCKDOWN.
THEY HAVE LEVERAGED THE FEAR.
THEY CALLED IT THE HERO’S ACT.
THERE WERE PARTS OF THE BILL
THAT WERE GOOD AND PARTS THAT
WERE TRANSPARENTLY POLITICAL.
ONE PART WOULD SEND OUT
APPROXIMATELY 160 MILLION
BALLOTS TO ANY JURISDICTION IN
THE STATE OF A MAJORITY.
THAT IS THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ALSO WOULD LEGALIZE THE
PRACTICE OF PAID POLITICAL
OFFERS TO COLLECT AN UNLIMITED
NUMBER OF BALLOTS AND RETURN
UNLAWFUL POLLING STATIONS.
ISIT IS ILLEGAL IN MANY PLACES
BECAUSE IT IS OBVIOUSLY AN
INVITATION FOR VOTER FRAUD.
IT INVITES OPPORTUNITY FOR
CRIMINALS TO INTERCEPT.
IT DOES OPEN THE DOOR TO
COERCION AND FRAUD.
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE WEEK.
THAT HAPPENED IN NORTH CAROLINA.
THE STATE INVALIDATED A
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTION LAST
YEAR.
SO, FOR THE PEOPLE PUSHING IT,
THAT IS NOT A CAUTIONARY TALE.
IT IS A BLUEPRINT.
IT’S WHY THEY ARE DOING IT.
ANOTHER CORONAVIRUS EMERGENCY
BILL, BY THE WAY, DISMANTLE MASS
INCARCERATION.
IT WOULD ALLOW FOR THE RELEASE
OF MORE THAN 100,000 PRISONERS,
INCLUDING VIOLENT OFFENDERS.
THE CHAIR OF THE HOUSE OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
THEY ALL SUPPORT THIS.
THEIR STATUS WOULD NOT BE
REVOKED UNLESS THEY ARE
LITERALLY CAUGHT HURTING
SOMEONE.
THAT IS IN THE BILL.
THEY ARE NOT MAKING THIS UP.
THIS ALLOWS INCARCERATED FELONS
TO LEAVE PRISON AND STAY FREE
UNLESS THEY "CAUSE BODILY INJURY
OR USE VIOLENT FORCE AGAINST AN
INDIVIDUAL."
SO, MURDERERS GET TO GO FREE BUT
YOU HAVE TO STAY INSIDE
INDEFINITELY.
NO ONE HAS TOLD THE RIOTERS THAT
THEY ARE ON MANDATORY HOME
CONFINEMENT.
NO, THEY ARE OUT IN THE STREET.
THESE COMMANDS HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE APRIL.
WE HAVE KNOWN THAT THIS WAS
BASICALLY A POLITICAL POWER GRAB
GRAB.
EZEKIEL EMANUEL TOLD US ON
TELEVISION.
WATCH.
>> REALISTICALLY, COVID-19 WILL
BE HERE FOR THE NEXT 18 MONTHS
OR MORE.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY UNTIL WE FIND A VACCINE
OR EFFECTIVE MEDICATIONS.
ALL THAT ECONOMIC PAIN, WE ARE
TRYING TO STOP COVID-19.
THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
WE WANT THE TRUTH IS WE HAVE NO
CHOICE, MEANING, THE TRUTH IS
YOU HAVE NO CHOICE.
WE ARE DOING THIS WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT.
NO ONE ASKED.
NOBODY CARES.
LAST MONTH, JOE BIDEN SAID THAT
HE WILL ACT ON THE COUNTRY IF
THE EXPERTS TELL HIM TO.
WHAT EXPERTS IS HE REFERRING TO?